la guerra no se apaga en el este de
ucrania clínicas infantiles atacadas y
miles de heridos en todo el país
atenderlos se ha convertido en una
misión difícil para los médicos como
esta doctora que gestiona un hospital en
libro prefiere no mostrar su rostro para
no poner en peligro el centro de salud
no ocurre ni una gran cantidad de
hospitales fueron destruidos en todo el
país a pesar de que tenían la bandera
blanca y que se entendía que eran
hospitales centros para niños
maternidades todos fueron destruidos
desde el cielo a tu gusto pese a los
constantes ataques a los hospitales
andriy quien llegó con una herida grave
en el brazo reconoce que ha sido bien
atendido
me habían puesto un torniquete y como
los combates continuaron no pudieron
evacuar me rápido y estuve mucho tiempo
en la mano con él y
tuve 170 centros sanitarios han sido
atacados desde el inicio de este
conflicto según la organización mundial
de la salud ataques en los que han
fallecido unas 70 personas
un combatiente de ser casi herido por un
ataque con misiles en donde se está con
vida gracias a la atención recibida en
este hospital de guerra
agradezco desde lo más profundo de mi
corazón a los médicos que me salvaron la
pierna me devolvieron esperanza y que la
paz pueda finalmente llegar a ucrania
los médicos que trabajan en ucrania se
encuentran librando su propia lucha y
con más fuerza porque son unos de los
principales blancos de ataque en esta
guerra